what's going on everybody you got to
check it out Barry walking around and
broad daylight in that future flash
costume we had to freak out about this
there's a couple big questions I know a
lot of you are like maybe we see a
little bit of him in the trailer but it
was so hard to tell I was like okay
we'll wait for more footage to confirm
it this officially confirms that this is
about as close as you can get to
confirmation what better time to give
away a new flash ring all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video
grant us that even posted this video of
him waving at fans like hey how's it
going everybody check out the new
threads right off the bat there are a
couple big questions like when did he
get this does he have new Speed Force
powers if he manifested this in the
Speed Force like based on the timeline
of episode 1 they wouldn't have time to
fabricate a completely new costume in
one did Cisco never saw like Cisco would
have had to seen a picture of the future
flash suit so that he could build it
himself so until we get some more
footage
it sounds like they just bring him out
of the Speed Force and he looks like
this like he just comes out looking like
the future flash now it's hard to tell
if this is the exact same costume or if
they've tweaked it a little bit because
of the really crap way that they color
corrected episode 19 last season this
was that scene where they debuted that
suit
I thought it was about time I did
something
let's go vadas now her powers won't
affect us we can go anywhere he does
[Music]
seemed pretty even now so as you can
tell the way they color corrected the
episode made it look a little different
shade of red this is what it looks like
in the cold light of day it looks much
better when they're not trying to drain
the color out of the episode to let
people that don't watch the flash know
that they're in a different timeline if
you ever wonder why they do that weird
sepia tone thing when they go to earth
to or why they drained all the color out
every time they went to the Future
during season three it's one of those
old TV tricks that all shows pull to let
casual viewers know that you're in a
different reality and it makes the show
look worse like they literally shoot it
to look very beautiful the costume looks
great under normal coloring but then
they go to this other time period they
drain all the color out you're like ah
what happened based on the comments that
Grant Gustin has been making about the
time the bear is spending the speedforce
how he's coming out not really knowing
what's going on he's going to be a
different version of Barry for a little
while like he'll have a little bit of
amnesia he won't immediately remember
everything that happened in the moments
that he left last season he's lived
several lifetimes so I guess that's a
way to justify him wearing that future
flash costume because that's from eight
years in his future he said that they're
not going to show you what happened
while he was in the Speed Force they'll
just address it in a federal way to help
him become this more mature version of
the flash through the course of season
four they kind of did this thing back
during season two where he goes into the
Speed Force it shreds his costume like
they literally have his version of the
costume here that they used to try and
find him again he becomes pure energy
has that adventure where he talks to the
Speed Force wormhole alien that looks
like his mother then realizes that he
never really lost his powers to begin
with in the camera sort of turns around
and he's all of a sudden wearing the
flash costume steps out of the Speed
Force wearing it too so I'm not really
expecting them to address the logic of
it because they didn't do that during
season two so there's no reason to
assume that they're going to suddenly
explain how this all works during season
four but in the comics he is able to
manifest his costume directly out of the
Speed Force it's this Nexus of pure
energy time and space so the more
powerful he gets the more he can
manipulate it it sounds like he's just
going to get a little bit
powerful this season but what about the
flash ring you're saying if he's more
powerful wouldn't you start using the
flash ring too new costume new way of
putting the costume on the only reason
why I'm not expecting that right away
it's just because it's expensive to do
that special effect in TV shows budgets
tend to go down over time so they try to
find easy ways to get him into that
costume so like there's a big crime
happening Barry's looking at his costume
says I need to go help these people out
they do that really blurry effect where
they disappear the costume and he runs
out the door and he just in it when he
gets to the crime scene you don't really
see it from Barry's perspective like you
don't see him pull the costume on one
leg at a time it'd be like watching
Oliver put his costume on it'd just be
kind of excruciating after you see it
once or twice but the other big question
is is that now the Barry's coming back
and we know that while he's going to be
in his old costume at some point during
season one what are they going to do
with that old costume is Wally going to
keep wearing it because Kenyon Lonsdale
just right before Comic Con had his mom
on set he was wearing the yellow version
of the costume again after they had
finished filming scenes with him in the
red costume so until we see more behind
the scenes from what it looks like his
episode 3 which I think they're filming
right now we're just assumed he's going
to go back to the yellow costume and
part of what I'm wondering is is that
they're going to slowly start making the
idea of the flash museum we probably
won't get to it for a little while but
we have the STAR Labs museum so maybe
they'll put the costume of that old
museum they've actually been using the
museum as a big plot point in the comics
the last couple of issues there's been
all this reverse flash stuff going on
and I know you're all still wondering
what's going on with him they didn't
really explain the comic-con what
they're going to do with the character
he always comes back
flash reborn reverse flash reborn at
some point - one of the most fun things
about the flash is the TV show just
doing something without explaining it
like pulling him out of the Speed Force
in this costume or just bringing the
reverse flash back and not explaining
the logic behind it and then just
leaving that for us the fans to try and
figure it out there'll be a lot more
behind the scenes like they're filming
episode 3 right now by the time they get
to the episode 1 premiere BB filming
that four-night crossover but it'll
probably be September before we see a
legit
episode 1 trailer believe all your bonus
video requests in the comments below I
know there's young justice to do so
that'll probably be my next video
there's still a lot of Comic Con stuff
to do young justice season 3 coming next
year but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner the golden gamer
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here to watch
my Infinity Ward trailer video and learn
all about the scrolls Captain Marvel and
you can click here to rewatch the
Justice League trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight